how's gum Roseman expiry pad welcome
back to another episode of alien
isolation we are isolated alright we
just escaped from some scumbags it looks
like everyone hates each other on this
chip but for some reason Captain Picard
here trust us isn't that right Captain
Picard I'm gonna kiss its forehead won't
let me I'll [ __ ] you too then I need to
do something in here I think how much
further
transitive ship still Lea I doubt it
quite what you expect again no I love it
my shipping out papers were for a week
ago let's check this out oh thanks I
didn't enjoy walking myself so yeah so
by strolling service law I get semester
linked a blind eye s I managed to get my
hands on that stuff I was talking about
chief won't even notice stock missing
thanks always get last don't worry about
customs either so you guys told us you
told his men to turn a blind eye they'd
probably be too busy be goofing off or
they blah blah blah okay so we get it
people act like jerks you can possibly
you want to read that I'm sorry I'm not
gonna read all the notes
I'll read the ones that I wanted to read
captain you go first captain what do you
say captain
that's good that's me kissing is for it
it's goal all right well I I guess I go
first then sick to my [ __ ]
tummy [ __ ] must think I'm about the
[ __ ] of cars off oh that's clever
good we need white to be both consoles
at the same time to open it I'll do when
you go to the one on the other side not
safe
okay this means we're gonna get split up
haha let's be honest that's what's gonna
happen right it's not a horror game
unless we're together on three one two
three
there we go
behind you behind you captain captain oh
I did it again tenten a tenten tenten
tenten I didn't did it in tintin tintin
tintin tintin tintin ha-doo-ken oh [ __ ]
sorry Wow I didn't do it dad I'm a man
let's go
the others are on their way you [ __ ]
murdered him No okay do that way we were
just playing and then gandalf here was
like i'm gonna let me just loot him ah
God yeah but I can't loot dead people
without getting shot at Jesus Christ
what is it no he's not sleeping I
promise promise sleeping come on Jesus
you killed that guy because he was going
to kill me you saved my life
this is about survival do you understand
I wouldn't oh god oh god what is
stripping I hear something hmm if I go
on me isn't that super tux
it's time to be a man a woman a woman
more man woman what the actual [ __ ]
[ __ ] that thing picks us off one by one
I can't I can't
the new eiffel Apple oh god we are so
[ __ ] god damn it I was starting to
like Captain oh [ __ ] we can't trust
anything now call transit please
Oh God Oh God
uhh
no this [ __ ] ambience can go [ __ ]
itself what is happening Oh God
why did I call the God forsaken trends
come on party the [ __ ] up come on come
come I come I come I come I come up to
me Coco Coco Coco what is this oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god
click click okay okay yeah click click a
button click a button click a button
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this I'm so
done I'm so done please take me out of
here I don't want this anymore
oh god oh god nothing even happened and
I'm this [ __ ] out man this is not gonna
be good bris this is not gonna be good
oh man
Jazz's crashed
lunar style that's my favorite magazine
of all time Oh God well at least were
away from that monster before they breed
attract and exterminate huh the vermin
cause diseases don't lettuce I think
we're gonna have a sensor later in the
game that's kind of cool actually all
right we're good here right right yeah
right
right right I don't want to hide cold
for transit uh-huh we just came from a
transit and why would we go again what's
our objective get to sex once
communications same station yeah my same
station very subtle this game subtle is
skiing or they know that which is not
good for me but hey what are you gonna
do passcode requiring slicing my torch
what the [ __ ] are all these things open
please thank you
hide no I'm not not gonna [ __ ] hide
I'm not scared of you and your no
weapons allowed well you can't tell me
what to do it's a butthole should we go
in well why not
my mom always said whenever you have the
chance to go inside a bottle feel free
to go do soap use that's collect craft
another med kit one can never have
enough med kits what other things can we
craft though why would I use a flare if
I have a flashlight
you seem very defenseless in this game
that's all I'm gonna say hello but thank
you but I always liked you alright we
should be safe here
emergency override
I locked the door oh I can do that with
doors oh my god
goddamnit let's be careful here okay
okay okay okay okay sorry sorry
emergency override oh god oh god I got
it oh [ __ ] I was one I need all of them
stop it vital
that is not [ __ ] cool man
surprise mother [ __ ] up oh they're
coming hey what do I do
help help pokerface pop-up okay face pop
up a poker face by a poker face
oh hello scaried my can't read my no you
can read my poker face there we go he's
dead
another one bites the dust ah Jesus I
didn't see you come on that's not cool
chill the [ __ ] out
chill out chill out relax and Max and
all : all shoot some ball outside a pole
when a couple of guys teaming up and no
good started making trouble in my
neighborhood I got a more little fight
and my mom got scared he said you're
movin with your auntie and uncle in Bali
I wit the pole cab and when it came near
hello everybody dead out here that's
kill are all dead let's take a cold
though you never know bro
this has been great thoroughly enjoy the
times we had together do you hear that
bro sir is it me I don't really trust
anything scrap pile of scrap scrap up my
ass if you know what I'm saying oh okay
I think we're good for now now let's get
up here this is where we need to go this
is how we party move and with your body
come on everybody
yeah yeah Sikeston they buy your system
boot air purification speaker system
alright cool
we don't need you right now think it's
more for stall thing and [ __ ] oh my god
this game makes me sweat that's
disgusting I stick around for loot and
stuff flare that's good
we need all the flowers we can get what
a cozy need low place is this I don't
know what I feel about you two
all right I think this is it yeah there
we go
the [ __ ] is that sound though don't
trust don't trust it one bit what do we
got it should be here somewhere where is
it where is it
I'm Batman or is it whoa holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that looks so [ __ ] epic look at that
awesome it's supposed to be at the
bottom tech support
let's check here first
oh it's a cargo okay well it has to be
in the tech support then what was that
what was that what was that me no like
or Didius oh god this game really plays
her their emotions man if they pushed
harder I don't know if I even would be
able to even their save station save
station
I gotta love my save station oh wait I
needed that one what are you doing here
then I tell you not to get back in oh
hello it's time to play a game called
where is it we got the key card to sweet
I don't know where it goes I don't know
who the hell is this
no I did not have a mental breakdown
this hat is for protection the aliens
they can't hear me while I wear it don't
worry they're everywhere
they got captain what the [ __ ] is he
doing sitting down on his ass Justin you
know there's an alien in servation
we got damn I got a look at all this
[ __ ] you know they're all empty
oh my lunch crate boxes are empty I
think I ain't going in there [ __ ] that
alright alright I have my garnet and I'm
not afraid to use it No Oh God that is
some hot funky leather [ __ ] you look
like you just been a [ __ ] they honor
the trip of his life we're max on
everything are you cereal ah
we need an RJC injector gosh - nut nice
kneepads bro good thing they didn't
shoot you there I'm saying what was that
I [ __ ] hear you here we go
flashback
what so now we can make a flashbang cool
let's do it
craft it item constructed boss [ __ ] you
umm I want to make another one please
now we're missing the blasting cap thank
you for that flashbang whoa look at it
it looks awesome
but you wish you had this your piece of
[ __ ] so how are we gonna use the
flashbang you know what I'll just keep
it and in case I run into trouble I'll
just chop this to show on boss hot cha
that's like a universal language for
back to [ __ ] off the flight recorder is
that good nor bad or good or bad or bad
good what what it what is she talkin
about someone erased the data J says
calm down there's an alien killing
people okay
focused oh hell no oh hell no oh oh my
oh [ __ ] me
this is not good
what are we looking for here you serious
hurry up
something is coming there it is okay I
found it
cool took me a while though yay how do
we use it
hack the elevator oh yeah that's going
back there sorry we used it on this
thing stay tuned in the code with mouse
and okay there we go
and then II to enter okay nope I'll [ __ ]
you too then
incorrect code ah that one and then that
one and then that one yeah hmm that's
kind of cool
I like that interesting a very
untrusting whoever came up with that
good job still there I would be creeped
the [ __ ] out of he wasn't another
blueprint smoke bomb good thing wouldn't
miss that Jesus one if we missed any
others
let's try and build one but about a path
that at bad benefit buildable butta
butta butta butta Papa Papa Papa don't
make me [ __ ] kill you geppu point you
hopefully the [ __ ] alien isn't here
yeah you're still here yeah bet you stay
here all day [ __ ] I don't like all this
blinky shiny stuff
gosh darn it all right we'll have to go
this way we both knew that I told don't
tempt me no champ to me batch all
alright let's use this again that yeah
hey yeah yeah hey huh
sorry I'll never do that again I'm a man
and there needs to do is vanity Steve
survive solo link my favorite computer
we got some personal stuff from Franco I
got some spaceship from let's do the
audio no wait we need the utility sorry
sorry sorry one second nope
well [ __ ] no audio either where [ __ ]
mating or my suppose all these sounds
make me so paranoid I like I don't even
know
revolver ammo good not that I know we've
been trying to use it can we just take
this and leave I would be okay with that
quick Nick good on them there we go
Deadite hmm we got this press don't
don't you worry don't you worry really
we're just walking a [ __ ] circle hack
the elevator - we're so close to it
we're so close
could it be here
everyone loves those space shoes man
they're really popular wish I could add
them for mega mega burger haha chick
chick maggots [ __ ] a lot of chick
maggots
here we are seriously it's so hard to
see
Oh God something tells me we Oh God
hi there friend how are doubt they'd see
us oh [ __ ]
are you serious
Oh oh well that's just nice and Dan yes
me what the [ __ ] that ass is magnificent
Syria oh god I don't think the gun is
gonna do much
where the [ __ ] did it go where the [ __ ]
did it go Oh God
where do we need to go this is not okay
this is not okay
I thought we did it Oh God I can't press
be gentle to me okay alright let's take
the bottle I'm all vitals I'm a big
[ __ ] fan of my holes I love every
kind of bubble doesn't matter who it
belongs to
no god I might have oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god I gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta get that
boom boom boom boom boom boom gotta
get-get alright sopin it's [ __ ] open
let's go rod up or down I'm moving on
around check your hands to the ground
take your parents in the pound one step
left and one step right all right we did
it
okay okay I think we're safe okay hurry
up hurry up
okay Oh God not this [ __ ] sound
what does it sound me alright we did it
granted thank you whoo your garage your
grant has been granted what was that
Oh God what is going on okay where did
it go
no no no neo neo neo I can't I am going
there
can I go anywhere else like anyone in
the entire planet oh god oh god okay
okay alright alright alright alright
guys this is skiing this game games
can't hurt us games can't hurt us as
schemed hurts anyone yes that has been
severed okay let's let's fix that best
yes you air purification at least I can
die with fresh [ __ ] air that's
great
oh we turned it off good job me I got
[ __ ] it's all smoggy out in an infinity
oh my god what is it going what is it
doing okay okay okay okay
we just need to hack this elevator we're
just gonna hack detail.you elevator now
like it all right that's good uh yes yes
uh uh okay okay
open up and up and up and up and up and
up and up and up and up and up and up
and up and up on open open open open
open open open open open open up open up
open up my best my best bud okay okay
see you later alligator hater scared
mater oh we did it
hi [ __ ] 500 I wasn't too bad wasn't it
that was quite nice I would say
still have my guide okay
I saw someone picaud is that you because
what the [ __ ] hello my name is Ripley
Amanda Ripley I need your help okay take
a seat someone will be with you shortly
no wonder sickness is in the tech race
what a [ __ ] BH plus a tech rate race
stupid Sikhs and stupid morons cease an
outdated tech I can shove better take
out of my my Technol whatever guys now
it door access give me that I can't
activate it for something okay
are they require three got it cool I can
control all these things through these
things that's awesome alright now we
should have a door access better wait we
lost our air purification
bring it on brittany.brittany space and
a diesel your your name we have all this
stuff but like what is it all full still
need more scraps and [ __ ]
I wanna have my gun ready you have to
hold down like where does it go inside
my belly or some [ __ ] like oh god what
happened
Oh what the foot hello st. amant I hear
that's good
I am torch I don't have an iron torch I
know why the game okay all right it's
selfie time or smacky smacky time either
way you know I'm okay hi boys
I miss you man shut up flare I don't
need you and your pity but I love your
pots I always loved you dude this is not
a dating sim game shut the [ __ ] up all
right we good we good in the hood what's
our objective here let's make your way
to the comms that's where they are
fan-fucking-tastic well at least then we
can control contact the [ __ ] okay they
won't hurt me right you guys are nice
right now make me [ __ ] you that's right
don't make me do it I need to get into
comms control it's urgent that is a
restricted area it's an emergency
don't you realize what's going on Apollo
has the situation in that your
registration is almost complete
first okay my birthday yeah I don't need
your helps to be bluey goddamn blues
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] they say what is
wrong with this chin anyway have some
plastic surgery if you know what I mean
they look like Captain Picard one of
these and that is not a very flattering
look if you ask me all right let's see
what we can get here rewire system [ __ ]
alright okay we have some air Pina
that's good
relay is good um yeah I don't know what
to say
give me a flare at some anymore power
about this collect motion tracker so
that's what I wanted that's what I
wanted it's modified okay it she like my
[ __ ]
hold space to use your motion tracker
whoa Oh Jason Jason
no no problem look at the graphics that
blur is amazing
whoa I can switch where my ice ones
focus how [ __ ] cool is that is there
a problem
[ __ ] jump [ __ ] let's think I'm about
the [ __ ] dummy
all right just unactivated air
purification and all that jazz
that makes more power available there we
go okay cool we sold it [ __ ] genius
he is at picking emmanuel open the door
leading at Stan's don't wait don't want
any accidents if we figure I was going
on error uproot operation not permitting
well son of a [ __ ]
first published February 2015 Jesus
Christ wonderful we don't want to show
you a new world we want to discover it
with you here at six and every new
technology research blah-blah-blah-blah
hope you'll join in
focus 2030 for change everything the
advent of faster-than-light travel put
six and wow so that's in twenty years
that's great the race in his face began
in earnest and under the steady hand of
our founder Josiah
saighe our company was primed and ready
for the years that followed Jesus
classes and light technology thanks
science and I didn't wait because I knew
you trying to tell me please understand
this is our best shot
someone's got to reestablish
communications sorry we need to make
sure the officials back at home know
what's going on here don't worry about
me I'll be back I'm not gonna make you
clear
I want to use the [ __ ] tracker Oh
meat that's meat it wasn't eat oh my god
that's disgusting
cool
still missing stuff
oh it's space all right not on space
it's so creepy you look at that what is
is that pointing to North or MSV right
all right I open the door here no wait
where did I open the door this door yeah
let's just take it really [ __ ] easy
night really [ __ ] easy mate I could
do it a safe station right now save
station a [ __ ] sound mate hell am i
safe hey Shan yes police thank you bring
it on bring it the [ __ ] on or I'm
opening BAM said Sam when he [ __ ] out
the lamb from his hair anger tang
yep that's space science for you [ __ ]
you think you can stop me I'm about to
get my snap-in degree in today I'm about
to get my master degree in Siberia watch
me no stops go 360 from a tree equality
[ __ ] how's this
a present for me why thank you
what a chargeback thank you
hahaha alright hey I'll take well you're
a little [ __ ] shut up me in I need to
contact my ship what a batch Thanks
there's gotta be another way inside your
chin man you gotta work on the chin I
got as amazing chin skills hi ki khatti
required okay my first question is why
do you look so ugly why can I sign up
for this questionnaire e another one I'm
lovely
it's like Christmas white whale it'd be
a little box hon this is like a 3d
printer what I've got Bonnie
agent emini that nope thanks what is
this how does it look like is this a
smoke bomb hahaha
alright let's do this system override
what you that was easy
so they're all different ones that's a
more classic one I would say the timing
one no animals got it cuz everyone
brings their bird on their space travel
yeah it's like I'm going to space I
better bring my bird
no no why why else what else should I
bring really alright shut up go death
pee-yew oh don't you recognize me this
is me
we've got to reestablish long-range
communications you're becoming
hysterical
hahaha get back I'm warning you oh Jesus
what that [ __ ] uh is he gonna Jesus good
day indeed good day indeed
alright rest got after that episode
there you enjoy watching go ahead and
hit that like button I really appreciate
it bros thanks for being so awesome I
love this series so far and I think you
really like it too you made it this far
uh then look forward for more that's
always stay awesome